we now have the bitmex ceo the new ceo
coming out and saying that they believe
that there will be five countries that
will adopt bitcoin by end of year big
mac's ceo alexander hopner thinks
countries in the developing world will
soon follow the footsteps of el salvador
he explicitly has come out and said two
things one he said quote my prediction
is that by the end of the next year
we'll have at least five countries that
accept bitcoin as legal tender all of
them will be developing countries so by
the end of 2022 i'm sorry not 2021 by
the end of 2022. then he says quote
vitalik and i can agree to disagree on
this one speaking about vitalik recent's
comments on bitcoin and el salvador he
said i celebrate the move towards
mass-market adoption of crypto and el
salvador and what will start with
bitcoin will quickly diversify of course
a move like this attracts criticism and
will never be perfect either but the
overall direction is undeniably positive
now when we think about this the idea
that el salvador has come and adopted
bitcoin as legal tender i think people
are really excited about that we've also
seen countries like brazil ecuador
argentina and many others various
politicians whether on the local level
or on the national level all start to
talk about following suit and so the
idea that we're gonna get five more
countries by the end of 2022 in my
opinion is actually probably pretty
realistic i don't know exactly if it's
five if it's six or four and i don't
know if it's by june of 2022 or december
but it feels like over the next 12
months or so there will be a handful of
other countries that start to
participate now that participation can
be in many different forms it could be
as accepting the digital currency as
legal tender it could be deciding to put
the digital currency on their balance
sheet their central bank it could also
be accepting bitcoin and the digital
currency as some form of payment in
terms of paying their employees or
letting people pay their taxes and fees
there's all kinds of different ways that
they can participate and it doesn't just
have to be about using it as a medium of
exchange or a store of value you also
could see countries saying you know what
we've got lots of energy whether it's
stranded energy or excess energy we're
gonna start actually mining bitcoin as
well and we're gonna use that to
monetize the power that we have access
to and use our very very low rates in
order to become super profitable and so
regardless of how these countries start
to participate it would not be
surprising to see five or so countries
in the next 12 months or so the question
then becomes where do we get them from
and when you think of a country like el
salvador it's about six and a half
million people it's pretty small on the
global stage but if you start to talk
about maybe a country like brazil which
there's been rumblings and rumors about
their bitcoin adoption that could become
much more interesting or if you look at
a country like the philippines where
we've seen other types of
blockchain-based assets become very
popular if all of a sudden they started
to adopt bitcoin as well they've over a
hundred million people from a population
standpoint and so whether it's a small
country or a large country whether it's
a developed country or developing
country i do think that we will see it
what i don't find as easy to wrap my
head around is to see one of the
superpowers go ahead and start to
participate even here in the united
states i think the federal government is
unlikely to start to embrace participate
in bitcoin in any material way but the
beauty of the united states is that it
is a union of states and those
individual states actually have more
autonomy than most people realize and so
we've seen in wyoming or texas or in
florida and many other states around the
country that people have become very pro
bitcoin and so i think that's where
we're going to see the movement most
likely is that the states will start to
actually embrace the digital currency
and the decentralized open payment rails
we'll start to see politicians realizing
that wait a second a big portion of my
step of my population of my constituency
they actually own this asset they care
about the ideals and the ethos that are
wrapped around the asset and this asset
specifically is good for business this
asset brings jobs to my jurisdiction it
allows us to derive more tax revenue and
on top of that it also creates economic
value and so i can create jobs if i can
create economic value if i can help my
constituency actually build a life of
financial security and on top of that it
drives revenue for the government then
it's actually
bitcoin being good for business and
already individuals have realized that
now corporations and financial
institutions are starting to realize it
but eventually even the government
whether it's at the national level the
state level or even at a local level
talking about cool valley missouri and
giving out the bitcoin directly to
citizens my guess is that whether it's
five countries or more or whether it's
in 12 months or less it ultimately isn't
gonna matter we're gonna see everyone
capitulate everyone participate but it's
very interesting to see that the bitmex
ceo now believes five countries will
adopt bitcoin before the end of 2022.
john do you agree or disagree with five
countries by the end of next year i
don't want to put a number on it so i do
not know how many countries i believe
more
go deeper down the rabbit hole of
bitcoin within the next year i mean he
he had some uh alexander has some great
points he is the former ceo of a german
exchange so he understands both macro
and micro like environment and uh
markets but he cited a few things
remittance payments were are gonna
accelerate the growth in developing
countries high inflation developing
countries and then also political issues
in developing countries uh some of the
stats where 75
of low and middle income countries uh
suddenly they receive 75 of the
remittance payments in the world which
is kind of wild to think about um and
then also just high inflation rates so
developed countries the average
inflation that the imf said was going to
be 2.4 and then developing countries
it's going to be 5.4 for 2021. that's a
pretty big difference in my opinion if
you had to guess right now let's try to
guess the five countries that are likely
to adopt bitcoin
brazil brazil ecuador
argentina
what are two more
five countries that you believe will
adopt bitcoin brazil ecuador argentina
mexico
colombia
then
venezuela
well venezuela venezuela yeah as well
all right so are we going forward i
don't know what their political
situation four of the five countries are
all going to be in south america south
and central america
i think i think the thing is like brazil
would be an outlier because they would
be they're a massive country right when
i think they're sixth largest in the in
in the world so they're a much much
bigger than a bigger country than alisal
or six million population but you have
to look for a country that has uh
high inflation obviously right inability
to do uh international remittances stuff
like that so there's like a few key
things you want to look for and i think
the smaller the country the better
because it's easier to implement and
scale right so el salvador uh
they implemented it i think legal tender
on september 7th so we're just over a
month now they have more people that
have bitcoin wallets now than
traditional bank accounts so over half
the country i believe now has uh wallets
that are active and bitcoin's price is
appreciated by 25 since that went live
right so for the first time in their
lives these people have watched their
purchasing power actually increase
rather than decrease so i think when you
look at it from other countries that are
in a similar kind of case and standpoint
that el salvador was in it's a real
model that you can look at and say hey
look this is working to some degree
right and there's obviously going to be
price volatility and other things to
deal with and and getting people to
download kind of uh your wallets and
doing all these things are not easy and
i don't want to i don't want to say that
everything's going to go as well as el
salvador seems to be going but
ultimately it can be really worth it
because el salvador is is putting the
blueprint out there and you can argue
all day about whether they should do
things or they shouldn't do them or how
they're doing them etc but at the end of
the day more people there have access to
international payments at a faster speed
uh and aren't paying the high fees that
they were paying through traditional
services like western union so i think
it's a really good thing and i think
what uh the best thing that el salvador
has done really in my opinion is uh the
ability to show that this worked right
and they're the first mover now it's
opening the door for other countries to
come in and say hey look we uh we're
willing to do this we see it's already
working somewhere else they're kind of
laying down the blueprint maybe we
changed a little thing here or there but
ultimately uh we're not going to be uh
given such a hard time by other other
people on the national on the world
stage and then there is this blueprint
that we can follow to actually get this
done
so i think whether it's brazil whether
it's you know other countries in south
america et cetera uh it really doesn't
matter but i would i would guess that
there's probably gonna be yeah three
four or five countries that do it within
the next 12 24 months
one country we didn't mention is panama
yeah which definitely is a possibility
uh also you could see cuba potentially
the people not the government trying to
adopt it if you look at other places
like uh ukraine or estonia you could see
them trying to lebanon right there are
some other countries people were putting
in in the uh uh comments but if i had to
pick the five countries that i think
will end up actually uh going ahead and
embracing bitcoin i'm going to go with
brazil
panama
ecuador
argentina
and my fifth one
the people
of lebanon not the government why is
argentina on your list
super high inflation 50 i think the
annual inflation in argentina is like 50
percent
so when you're going based off inflation
if you have high inflation you have to
find something i believe that bitcoin
adoption at a nation-state level whether
it's actually the government embracing
it or it's a big portion of the
population embracing it is going to be
not driven
by a pitch of come buy this asset and
you can quote make money
i think that investors a small portion
of the population will be attracted to
that we've seen already 100 plus million
people around the world have been
attracted to that uh story
i think that the mass adoption occurs
less because people are just randomly
running to some asset that they think
will appreciate in uh kind of a fiat
currency price but instead they're
running from a really bad situation
they're running from 50 inflation
they're running from uh being a
dollarized country and having uh
censorship be uh um top of mind they're
running from the inability like in
lebanon right now for them to actually
be able to access their savings because
the banks are shutting down and not
giving them their money right so when
you think of it whether it is from a
confiscation standpoint whether it's
from an inflation standpoint whether
it's from a censorship resistance
standpoint all of these different things
once you've experienced the problems
the value prop of bitcoin becomes much
more obvious and so i think that the
mass adoption occurs not from people
just randomly running to it instead
they're running from a bad situation and
so what you have to do is to go look to
see where that adoption actually occurs
you have to go find where are the places
in the world where there's the most uh
kind of bad situation or the most pain
around the confiscation of assets
inflation yes
you think it's going to be more based
off the store value aspect than the
medium of exchange i think that you have
to get people to buy into uh kind of
psychologically that it is a store of
value and then they'll start using it as
a medium of exchange right there's kind
of a sequential thing you don't just
start using it as a medium of exchange
without thinking that it's a store of
value and then on top of that too is uh
the whole idea of censorship resistance
there's many people who may come into
bitcoin and use it in some of these
countries we're talking about who
actually aren't coming because they
think it's a store of value or because
they think that it's a more superior
means of uh exchange instead they're
coming for because literally it's
censorship resistance or literally if i
hold my private keys no one can take it
from me and so it just depends on what
is the situation that you're essentially
running from or trying to cure and then
that is why bitcoin ends up being
attractive to you it's similar it's this
very interesting thing where bitcoin has
so many different value propositions to
different people bitcoin ultimately ends
up being valuable to an individual
person for different reasons and a lot
of that is determined by what is the
situation that they either have
experienced or that they're running